Suppose we have the parsing state:
(E --> to E + E), and we've seen it all.
There's nothing more in the future to see
for this particular rewrite rule.
Coming from chart state [B],
we've previously seen (B) hidden tokens that aren't shown here on the left
and this is all in chart state [A].
I'm leaving (A) and (B) abstract
so that we know how to write a general program that does this.
We decided we wanted to look for (E --> E + E)
all the way back in chart state [B]--
all the way back, after we'd seen B inputs.
So if we view this as our input
or sort of the bottom edge of our parse tree,
as we're working on constructing it,
these are some previous input tokens--
maybe previous ints, previous pluses,
maybe parentheses--if we extend our grammar.
And at this point, we decided:
I think I'm going to see an (E + E) in the future.
And now we have.
We've seen all three parts of it.
So conceptually, it's as if we've seen the (E) right here.
Let me firm this up with a concrete example.
Let's go back in time and look at where we came from.
Suppose I extend our grammar so that is has both
Addition and Subtraction--whoa, the power--let's not get drunk!
And one of our previous states in chart [B]
had been: (E --> to E), minus--this is where we were,
and we were expecting an expression in (E).
So by reduction--by prediction--
we would have added in expectations to see
things like (E + E).
And in fact, that's where we got this state--that's why it says "from B"--
we brought it in in chart state[B], based on doing the closure here.
Well, now we seen enough input to actually make a single (E).
We've seen (E + E); that reduces to (E).
So it's as if we have this (E) in our input
and we're going to shift over it.
In some sense, this third approach--doing reduction--
is like a combination of the previous two.
If I've computed the closure in the past,
and now we've seen enough of the input
to actually use a reduction rule,
it's as if I put an (E) in the input
and we're going to shift right over it.
So I'm just going to shift my finger over one,
shift it over this (E)--where did this (E) come from?
It came from here.
We'd finished seeing all of its subcomponents.
We now have a big (E)--whoop! We're done with it.
Here's the real trick: this is one of the tricky parts of doing these reductions--
note which chart state I added it to.
We added it back to chart[A]
because I don't want to forget that we've already seen a lot of these tokens.
Remember the particular index we're using into our chart
corresponds to how many of the input tokens we have to have seen so far.
(A) was the farthest to the right, (B) over here.
We definitely want to remember that we've seen
all of these tokens in order to get to this point.
This is the trickiest rule, so we'll do a worked example together,
and then I'll ask for your input.
Let's say we have the following grammar--if you look carefully at it,
there's actually only one string in the language of this grammar:
(a, bb, c).
But I've added some extra nonterminals so that
we'll get a chance to see how (bb) reduces to a bigger (B),
by applying this rule in reverse,
and then we keep going and do all the parsing.
Unsurprisingly, the input will be: (a b b c).
The only string in the language of the grammar, it's "bee-tastic".
And now I'm going to work on making the chart.
So let's say we haven't seen any of the input yet.
We pick our starting nonterminal and, by convention,
that's just the first one I mention.
And actually, this is all there is; there's only one rule for the starting nonterminal.
We haven't seen any of the input yet,
and this red dot is not before a nonterminal
so there's no closure operations to do.
So we're totally fine--that's our entire parsing chart state.
Now let's say we've seen one part of the input.
We've seen the first token, (a).
Well, that matches up exactly with the token we were expecting,
to the right of the red dot,
so we get to shift over it.
And now I want to go back and make sure that we're recording
all the right information.
Officially, we need (from)-or position information--
for each one of these parsing states.
So here, we came from zero--we hadn't seen any tokens yet.
This rule, we brought over from the previous state by shifting.
It's still (from) position zero.
There's nothing in the input that's not already visible here on the right-hand side.
But now I'm going to bring in the closure,
and we decided to perform the closure in state[1].
So we write a (from1) here.
Another way for you to think about this (from) or starting position is:
there's really one more token--the (a)--
that would be here on the left, but I'm not including it.
So that's the one token we're missing.
Here, the next input token is a (b).
So can we shift on any of these rules?
Well, this has a dot before a nonterminal, so we can't do anything here.
But this one has a dot before a token--
and it's the token we were expecting--we are so happy:
(B goes to bb from 1)
Now let's make the chart for 3 characters in the input.
We've seen another (b)--so we go and look back previously.
Are there any shifts we could do--oh--we could totally shift over that (b).
All right. So here is the moment of truth
for performing reductions
We have the red dot at the end of a rule.
There's nothing to the right of it,
no more input to consume.
So we're going to apply this (B --> bb) rule
in reverse.
So we're going to look back to state[1].
We're going to use this (from) information--
Where'd it come from? It came from state[1]--
and see: I could turn this (bb) in the input
into a big (B), using this rule.
Is there anyone who wants to see a big (B)?
Back in state[1]?
No--yes, there totally is!
This rule here: (T) goes to (a) dot (Bc)--
it's really looking to see a big (B).
But we just made one--
by reduction, by applying the rule in reverse.
So, conceptually, you could go back and say:
Oh--what if we'd seen this big (B) in the input?
We've seen it right over here: (abb).
Instead of seeing these two lower case (b)'s, we'd see the upper case (B).
We'd take this rule--
and transplant it over to this state,
being careful to retain the original (from) information.
Now let's just interpret this (from) information.
Starting from zero tokens,
we've seen (abb) in chart state[3],
and those are all represented--
they're all encoded in everything before the dot.
In some sense, this lower case (a) has length1
and this upper case (B) had length2.
Those two, together, add up to three.
So I don't need any more hidden tokens to be in the third chart state.
So this last part, where I--from here, Step 1--
went back over to here and found this rule,
and then brought it back over here--
1, 2, 3--this 3-step process--
is reduction.